[Music]
hey andrew um
so
how do i get like a six-pack quick
what's the best fastest way to get a
six-pack why does it have to be quick
why does it have to be easy why do you
think life is all quick and easy why
can't it be hard and difficult why can't
you suffer because suffering is what
gives it value if everyone had a
six-pack and it was quick and easy then
it wouldn't be valuable would it if
everyone walked around with a quick
six-pack and they got it easily then no
one would give it the whole point is
that it's difficult value is linked to
difficulty if you want something that is
valuable you need something which is
difficult to obtain you shouldn't be
thinking about quick and easy you should
be thinking about hard suffering pain
going through it that's what you should
be thinking about this is going to be
hard but i'm going to do it anyway
because when it is done then everyone's
going to know that i went through
something difficult
nobody
absolutely nobody
gives a [ __ ] about you as
nobody cares about you as much as they
need to care to fix your life but nobody
is going to come to your bed drag you
out of bed [ __ ] drag you to a job force
you to work hard you are never going to
have any of the things you want if you
do not get them yourself the only person
is going to make me happy and live a
life that i want to live is me nobody's
going to do it for me people say tate
what motivates you and i find that
extremely i think that's a stupid
question
i was a four-time kickboxing world
champion for 12 years i trained five
hours a day six days a week and i was
motivated to train probably about 25 of
the time the rest of the time i went
because i am disciplined if i wake up
and i'm unhappy
i will do the exact same things as if i
am happy i will go to the gym the same i
will work the same how i feel has no
impact on how i live my life we're
grown-ups and we have responsibilities
and we have problems and we have
pressure and you don't necessarily have
to be happy to perform you know and
happiness will come at the end of the
performance anyway but if your number
one goal is a man if your number one uh
mission in life is just to be happy
that's it could be an extremely
vaporious existence you're not gonna be
a man of substance your ability to deal
with stress the amount of stress you can
deal with as an individual is directly
correlated to your success if you can
deal with stress all day you're gonna be
successful if you collapse under stress
you're not going to be successful
there's no way to the talk without
stress involved
but there is a massive correlation
between success and life and stress
holders
the more stress you can tolerate the
better your life's going to be one of
the only things in this world
you can control is your state of mind
you can't control the weather you can't
control other people you can't even
control your health
one of the very few things in the world
you have genuine control over is your
state of mind if you can't control that
then you're just a feather in the wind
and life's gonna blow you around i can't
imagine
truly wanting to quit something and not
being able to quit i can't imagine it
when i talk to people who say i want to
quit smoking i say when they all well
soon
that means you don't want to quit
you want to keep smoking for a while and
quit later i can't imagine a mind frame
or a mindset where i want to do
something and can't do it it's almost
difficult for me to answer that question
because if you have that kind of mind if
your mind is so fundamentally broken
that you cannot do with your own mind
what you want to do then you're just
right life is hierarchical there's
always going to be kings and there's
always going to be peasants if you have
a mind that you can't control then
you're never going to be a king you're
going to be a peasant that's your life
you have a peasant's life ahead of you
and that's your that's your destiny
enjoy right there's always been peasants
that's life but
i i believe that the most important
thing you can do as a man is to gain
control of your mind once you have
control of your mind life is so
ridiculously easy
people say to me tate you're in good
shape all you do is drink vodka and
travel the world you're never even home
you never even have a gym how do you do
it it's ridiculously easy if you control
your mind
if i decide to do a thousand push-ups
i'll do them maybe i have to do one at a
time maybe i'll get tired maybe i need a
break i'm gonna do a thousand because i
said i'm gonna do a thousand everyone
knows what they're supposed to do
you either control your mind or you
don't
and and this all of these things stem
from the same problem it's something you
can do it's something that is learned
something that is taught depression is
the ultimate motivation if you're
unhappy with your life and you're
depressed i don't expect you to be
popping pills to sit and lay in bed i
expect you to give me a huge list of
everything you're achieving per day
depression's a fantastic motivation you
know but people are told the opposite no
a lot of people's problems are all in
their mind and i'm not saying that
mental conditions aren't real because
absolutely some are but i try and
explain to people look the only thing on
the planet you have genuine control over
is your state of mind you can't control
the weather you can't control anything
the only thing you can affect in genuine
real time is how you feel in your head
how you view the world absolutely and
utterly shapes how you react to the
world how you act in the world how
people view you it's all down to how you
view things you have to believe with a
[ __ ] man and you have to believe you
can achieve anything i'm not saying you
can achieve anything easily i'm not
saying it's not gonna take a whole bunch
of work i'm not saying it's to happen
quickly but you have to believe you can
achieve anything when i tell people that
you are the sum of the five people you
spend the most time with everyone agrees
they go yeah that's probably true
and then they continue to hang around
with people who they don't want to be
why
there has to be a point where you sit
and go okay you're my friends etc etc i
love you guys yeah we can talk whatever
but i want a different life path
you have to leave some people behind if
you were to come hang around with me and
my crew you would be self-conscious and
that self-consciousness would motivate
you or they would certainly instill the
discipline required for you to change
you don't feel self-conscious amongst
your peers that's why you don't change
when i was broke
i couldn't sleep
and i say that people laugh i'm not
joking when i i wanted money
like [ __ ] i needed air people say to me
i want to be rich and i say okay well i
want to be able to ice skate but i don't
want to be able to ice skate enough to
go learn how to ice skates i can't be
bothered i mean surely if i could click
my fingers and be a figure skater i'd
click my fingers who wouldn't but i
don't want to actually go train this is
because i don't i don't want it enough
and this exact point with money everyone
wants money put on their lap if you
truly wanted money
you wouldn't be able to sleep until you
[ __ ] had it and this is the point
because when i had nothing i couldn't be
distracted
you couldn't distract me from what i
wanted life when you're young is a
completely different experience to life
for your own when you're older your life
quality seriously decreases massively
so you have about 10 to 15 maybe 20
years to find a way to get rich and
enjoy being rich and you got to put it
all together and you got to do it quick
you have to start saying i want to take
money
because that's how you have to think
you don't make it
you take it you have to start talking
that way you've got to take money is
that money isn't real
money
is like water
money never stays still if you can find
and identify a place where money is
moving
if you can find a place where money is
moving and stand in the way
then the money is vulnerable
problem is with any people out here
everyone has a dream
but not many people have a plan a good
plan today is better than a perfect plan
tomorrow you got to do something you got
to do something fast you're just sitting
around talking about it and hoping for
things to get better i don't think
living in a dream is going to help you
in any way i think you need to be
sitting here panicking at the fact that
you don't have enough money you need to
be concerned and worried and sad you
need to do something about it today
because that's how i started my first
business to maybe a million dollars i
sat in my room pissed off and i [ __ ]
came up with the idea most people see
people with things they want and they
don't do the second half they don't try
and work out how they got that thing oh
my man is a ferrari okay
i wish i had a ferrari okay they don't
sit there and go for an hour how did he
get a ferrari it doesn't cross that that
part is the part they don't want to do
right they just go oh here's a ferrari
wish i had a ferrari and they go back to
tv yeah and that's why they lose you
need to understand that in this world
there's a whole bunch of people doing
amazing [ __ ] you are not doing and that
needs to piss you off because it pisses
you off you become motivated all of a
sudden
you need to be annoyed and i'm telling
you i'm telling you to be angry
anger is a fantastic force you take that
anger and you direct it in the correct
direction and listen you may be phil
fired up for 10 minutes after this
little talk but you're not going to feel
fired up forever you need to put systems
in place you need to get disciplined you
need to get a atmosphere of people
around you who are going to keep you
accountable and not make it easy for you
to continue to be a [ __ ] nobody and
then you're going to fix your life
otherwise you're going to stay nobody
if you were genuinely pissed off about
your situation you would not need me to
motivate you you would motivate your
[ __ ] self and you would do something
to change it yourself motivation isn't
real everyone says this motivation is
not real discipline's real i do not feel
like training but i still train because
i'm a disciplined individual you don't
get to go through life only doing the
things you feel like doing